let's enter
round two with entrepreneurship and this
is where i made a critical mistake to
keep somebody on
way too long and it cost me it cost me
um my best friend
uh it cost me about i'm going to say two
to three years
of my life and focus um it was a big
waste of time
and this is probably one of the biggest
anchors in my life um
introduced one of my best friends to my
business he was um
i don't want to get into too many
details because i'm trying to keep
certain information anonymous but
basically for two to three years
brought this guy in there was no roi and
some people say what's
what's roi rich what's or they'll spell
it roy in the comments it's
roi return on investment for those of
you that haven't heard it
there's no return on investment with my
time
with this guy okay it probably cost me
i don't know 100 120 grand uh to employ
him
over the period of time paying for a lot
of stuff for him
um you know we had a network
that i had to maintain and part of that
was the social environment that was
around it
so it was like if there was a weekend
away in vegas
and i was going and he didn't have money
well
guess who paid for it right um you know
there's parts of it where
there were people chasing him down for
money and then coming after me
but at the end of the day i ended up
financing a few years of that
and got almost nothing back on return
investment
with the exception of the lawsuit that i
had to launch which cost me
another 20 30 000 uh in legal fees and
all the time that was involved in it and
what held me back in the business so
literally for
two to three years the business just
tread water this was
this was my first um big stab it's
something that
that was working i knew that it was
working i had a lot of
um evidence i had a lot of demand for it
i also had a lot of people trying to
compete and steal the idea um
customer list contract list stuff like
that um
i held onto that anchor for three years
too long i should have never
anchored with this i should have never
allowed my sailboat to
stop at this anchorage so
this is really how people have operated
for hundreds of thousands of years guys
they would sail around the world
taking advantage of the trade wings
trade winds that would bring them to
their next protocol and they'd have
these safe passages you have to look at
life
i believe anyway in a similar sort of
way there's certain areas that you're
going to stop at
you're going to have your anchorages
you're going to have anchors that you're
going to you know
need to use there's other things that
are going to hold you back maybe there's
weather delays maybe there's other
things that come
around that hold you back but a lot of
these things if you
if you're attentive to your life and not
sleep walking through it like most guys
do
me inclusive
you can get far better results far
quicker
than dragging around these enormous
anchors
for much of your life
you